here in europe it's uh
midnight so um
i'm not quite as fresh as i used to be
at conference but let's let's start
my name is michael stipe uh i'm a
microsoft mvp
and i'm one of the authors of the hot
chocolate graphql library for
net and today i want to talk to you
about graphql in general
what it is why you should care about it
and what we can do with it with asp.net
core
because i think a lot of you are net
developers
so what is this graphql actually what
can we do with it
why is it why does it exist so graphql
originally was
developed by facebook in order to solve
their
data fetching issues between the backend
and their mobile applications
and let's just head into some
graphql and explore what it is
so if we look at this simple graphql
query here
then we basically ask the server
for the currently signed in user and
from this currently signed in user
for the name and if we send that to a
graphql server
we would get a response that closely
aligns
our to our request it almost
is as if the graphql server just fills
up our request
with some data it is not like that but
it's a good mental picture to start
thinking about graphql
but as our maybe we
as our use cases change over time
we don't have to change our back end we
just
can't change our requests for instance
we ask
for the profile picture of that user and
we might want to know the width the
heights and the ul of the
profile picture again the graphql server
would
respond with some predictable results
that closely align our
request and if we look closer at
this actually we can see that graphql is
not about flat data structures or sparse
fields
we can see that it's actually about data
trees
and if it's about data trees we actually
can
push data aggregation now back to the
backend
like in this example we are exploring
related
objects to our user we are fetching not
only our user
we are also fetching the friends of our
user
but if we look closely at our request we
can see also some repetitions here like
name and last scene is added two times
and if you think about larger graphql
requests they would
become a problem with copy pasting so
graphql has introduced for that
something called a fragment a fragment
in graphql
is a primitive of composition you can
build
fragment hierarchies with that like you
can build component hierarchies in your
ui components and class hierarchies in
your background
but enough about this here the
theoretical constructs about graphql
looking about graphical queries
i actually prepared a little exercise to
get us all started
with graphql and understand the problems
better so i hope you all know some
star wars because there is a api which
is called
swappy.com it's an exceptionally rest
api
that tries to teach some principles of
rest
let me switch over this
star was api has a ton of star wars data
like the characters
the planets the films and other things
what we want to build now or the
experiment we want to do
is to fetch all the characters just a
list of names of characters
that played in movies alongside luke
skywalker
a simply enough task so let's first
explore our rest api
of um explorer rest api and check how we
can do that
so our rest api exposes some resources
here like the people resource
we could do a simple fetch on that and
then we might get a list of
characters like luke skywalker 3 cpo
and so on and if we look at that data
we can already see that each of these
entities or characters has its own ui so
we could
fetch a specific character instance
like this three cpu and this character
instance
exposes a list of movies
and these movies are represented by
reference so i can
fetch this movie for instance
and get some data about that
star wars movie like the episode id the
title
and i can see the characters that
appeared in that a movie
and i could drill in deeper and with
this information i already
kind of know how to create this
algorithm to fetch this
list of names um and this is the only
javascript you will see today
but i built up a little benchmarking
here
so um i built up a little functioning
in javascript to fetch the characters
that appeared
alongside luke skywalker in star wars
movies
for that i fetched the luke skywalker
character from the rest api
and then iterated over the films array
and then i fetched each of the films
and the films exposed this characters
array
so i fetched each of the characters that
appeared in that film
and then extracted did some data
massaging extracted the name and built
up the list
so let's have a look how that performs
so this is my little benchmark i
pre-run it just uh to be sure that it
works
it took 2.9 seconds which is not bad for
all the data we had to fetch
so let's uh run it live and see how it
turns out now
we can see that we are aggregating a ton
of requests it's actually the same
same amount of time here but we
aggregated a ton of requests and fetched
a ton of data so that cannot be very
efficient
let's explore how we would do something
with uh with graphql
so there is uh something called graphql
ids
this graphql ide is built by our open
source
project it's called bananakpop like we
have we
have a lot of special names
and with that we can explore graphql
endpoints
i built the stars api
for graphql and this star wars api
actually fetches the data
from the same rest service that we used
uh
just a few seconds ago and
when i open the graph by endpoint in my
graphql
ide i can click here on the schema
button and explore what the data is
about
for instance i see that my graphql
endpoint has a query root type and
exposes some fields
in this instance a character field
and if i click on that i can see that
the character returns a
character here with some properties like
eye color
a movies array that exposes movies and i
could drill into that see that i can
actually look at the movie that the
character played in and i also see that
it
again explores some characters okay so i
kind of have the same structure as my
rest api
but i also can see that i need to
provide an argument the id
so let's have a look at how we can build
something with that
let me switch back here so in graphql we
already saw in the initial
examples of graphql aquarius we start
with some squiggles
and then we basically define from what
we want to fetch some data
for instance we fetch the character and
the character one which should be luke
skywalker
and then we can pick from the properties
that we have there
for instance the name now let's just
fetch the character we can see boom we
get luke skywalker
okay but actually we want to really get
all the movies
and from the movies the characters that
played alongside luke skywalker
so we fetch the movies
and from the movies we fetch the
characters
and from the character's name and
actually luke skywalker's way
the name we don't need we just want the
names of the characters that played
alongside
alongside luke skywalker let's fetch
that
45 milliseconds the same rest api
but it doesn't have to transfer to it
down to me and i don't have any
cascading requests and
i basically don't have to write any code
in javascript apart from
destructoring here my response structure
to get just a list of names
so let's go to our benchmark
let's just head have a look at our
developer tools
as we did with our rest request just run
that
yeah 247 milliseconds so it depends on
how fast we get the data from the rest
service and we can see we just have two
requests
okay that's quite quite awesome um we
have a multiple times faster request
we don't have a lot of connections and
that's
exactly why um facebook developed
graphql
in order to get rid of the aggregation
of data on the client side
because on mobile applications with a
bad connection to the internet this
really matters
and it also matters on my system where i
have one gigabit
internet connection because it still
took 2.9 milliseconds to fetch the data
okay with graphql i only have one
endpoint
because i only need one endpoint because
i
as the consumer define what requests i
want i def
i craft them and i send them to the
server
and that means i also can fetch all the
data that i need at one specific
moment in time with one request
and this gets really rid of the over and
under fetching problem on the client
side
meaning over fetching is basically when
i had
to consume all this data from luke
skywalker the firms and all the
characters
that i actually don't need i just needed
the list of names
and under fetching is when i had to
fetch
another request that is cascading when i
basically built
up those cascading request pipelines
where each request
had to wait for the previous request and
basically my data fetching was
unparallelizable
and graphql is built on a strong type
system that means
if graphql tells you that a field is a
string then this field is a string and
will never be an hint on the client side
and if graphql tells you something is
never null it will never be known
and this really lets you
write code in a different way on the
client side because you can do
assumptions about the data
but apart from that graphql is not only
just simple fetch
and and pushing data to the server it's
also real time
and we will look at that in our
examples that we will do in a minute
so we could also do a lot of this with
rest
we could build very specific endpoints
that fetch everything very
very efficient for us but with rest we
also
we always have to work together with our
backend engineer we have to define um
new resources new endpoints which
basically gives us the data more
efficiently and we
all know that uh maybe our backend guys
have no time it goes back to the backlog
it
slows down the front-end engineers also
there's a lot of negotiation between
backhand and front-end engineer
and there's a lot going wrong with this
so
uh with graphql we don't have that
so what is graphql graphql is a
query language for your api and
it's a runtime to execute those queries
and graphql is really thought from the
business layer so when facebook started
developing that
the backend engineers came together and
thought about how they could
expose the business layer in a much
better way
so graphql gives you a much richer way
to expose your backend
data but graphql is also great as a
gateway technology where you bring
together all those microservices that
you have
in the back end and build this
ubiquitous um
a data graph which is which we present
the
single source of truth of your business
model
so graphql reverses the responsibilities
and gives the consumer the power to ask
exactly for what they want nothing more
but this also in turn frightens some
back-end developers
because now you basically have the power
to
drill into arbitrary data of the
back-end and fetch like you want and
how can we as a back-end developer now
make sure that
uh some requests don't kill our server
so actually graphql is not only a query
language
it's also a data definition language and
this is actually
the chance for us second developers to
mold
uh our data graph or mold how the
consumer of our
api can access our data how does the
front-end engineer really interact with
us
what costs do we allow for queries
and how is uh how is this front-end
developer able to access our data we can
all mode this
in a very strong way
okay so in graphql we have three or
three operation kinds there's query we
saw that
basically side effect we side effect
three
patches of data then we have something
called mutation which is a put post
patch delete of
rest and it's basically what produces
side effects
and then we have something that we don't
have in rest it's called subscription
and it's a
basically real-time data you have
something like that
with websockets or signalr but on a much
lower level with graphql
it's basically as if you were consuming
a graphql query and we will see that
before we get into our demos let's also
talk about what graphql is not
graphql is not a graph database query
language
it in fact has nothing to do with
databases
or any uh graph databases or databases
or it also has nothing to do with odata
if you look at all data odata is more
designed like
sql query like you have all those filter
methods you know
it's very close to a database uh query
language and it was also designed with
this mental picture when it started as
adam pop
with its atom pub format format a few
years ago
but graphql really was designed from the
api layer perspective so it's much
richer graphql is not a good
solution for binary students and netflix
is really using graphql
but they're not using it to stream
movies so it's good for
structured data
and some misconception is also around
that graphql is for http but it's
actually transport agnostic so it works
over grpc it works over
hdp it works over websockets about tcp
whatever you want and one misconception
that
actually i said in the beginning is not
true
is that it's not designed for the
javascript world
actually the first graphql server was
not written in node
and it was uh written in a php
by facebook and also the uh
front end consuming clients were written
in native
um were written native clients
for mobile applications so it had had
nothing to do with
actually web in this instance or with
javascript
okay let's explore how that actually
works let's see some code
let me get rid of this browser here
and then let's head into
some code
okay
so i opened up visual studio code this
is actually
an empty project there's nothing at the
moment
so the first thing we do is we create a
new solution
um let's call it demo
and the next thing we do is create a new
project
let's create a new web project
and let's call it also demo
and just uh add it to our solution
as a hat demo
and now we have a proper web project
here
actually um it's a standard empty
asp.net core web application there's
nothing special to it
we have our startup that we know
there's nothing in here it's just a net
five application
and since we are doing dot net five we
are using our brand new
graphql server today that is
still in preview like dot net five we
will release it alongside dot net five
so we are doing dot net add package
let me add package to demo
and it's the hot chocolate
hp net core package in version
11. preview
154 let's add that
let's just reload the solution so
everything is indexed correctly
and go into our startup cs
so every graphql server actually starts
with a query
a query is what you need for a graphql
server
if you don't have a query type you don't
have a graphql server
and mutations and subscriptions are
optional but you need to have something
to query
so a query type actually is
represented in dotnet as a class query
you can name it differently you can call
it foo but
it's up to you but it is
a class and you need some resolvers on
it
resolvers are the fields that fetch the
data for you
so if i write here something like a
public string
say hello and
return a string hello and this is our
resolver and i could query that
let's make it more exciting let's say we
have a string here
with a name
and we type the name in here
and by default it actually is
michael i know michael so let's run that
project demo
okay let's grab that
so a graphql server by default is hosted
on
is hosted on the endpoint on graphql
i just can't call that actually i should
be
oh we forgot something we created this
query type
but we didn't actually create our schema
so the first thing we need to do is
actually
create our query type and set up our
schema
and this is basically done by using the
service collection here
saying add graphql server
add query type and then we add our query
type here
and the second thing we need to do is to
add something
that executes our graphql server so we
use the endpoints api and set
say map graphql
and now we repeat
what we did we start our server
go into our chrome here and now on
graphql
is our graphql id
which i get rid of this and this is uh
basically
a served up when you go with the browser
on this endpoint we will serve up a
banana cake pop so you have something to
debug square
and okay so i can go now here in my
schema explorer and see
i have a field say hello here it is a
string
it's actually a nullable string and we
will see why it's that in a bit
and i can now query for this graphql
field here
say hello and i get hello michael
and i could also see that
i can say hello sydney
and then i get hello sydney here so the
the
um schema builder of hot chocolate will
inspect what c code you write and infer
from that actually your graphql schema
if we look at that we can already see
that it's really
the default value that is correctly
inferred
but everything here is nullable and
graphql has a concept of nullability
and that's why we should also enable
nullability
in graphql like we should say nullable
enable
let's reload this code so it reloads the
the project file let's restart that
re-fetch our schema and we can now see
this
exclamation mark and that means this
field is non-nullable
so it doesn't allow null and when i
now fire that it actually executes the
same but if
i would provide null here it already
squiggles me here and says okay you
cannot
you cannot put null in here and if i
would execute
that it actually allows me now which is
not good
as i said it's a preview and
i just found a nice bug
that's interesting okay
let's head into the next uh next demo
so we did our first graphql server
awesome and we also found the bug for
our v11 server
i will look at that after the talk
okay but this is just a simple example
like in real life you would actually use
something like maybe entity framework
mongodb
some database uh some proper objects to
expose in your graphql api so how would
that work actually how would a graphql
server develop when we put proper
objects in there
so let's get back to our graphql server
availability no nullability has to be
enabled
to enable nullability compilation there
was a question i didn't
don't know if you see if it shouldn't be
disabled
so if you enable nullable it means that
the
uh that the compiler now annotates these
um reference types in a.net
and now i have nullable reference types
so if nullable is enabled
actually reference types like this
become nullable reference types
and this would be another version so
this means if i run that
i would now let's refresh that
get a nullable version of the argument
here
and actually the execution engine should
have raised an
issue for me providing null here
but that is uh so we have a stable
version 10.5
the this version is actually x uh coming
out at the end of october
so there are still some bugs but it also
lets me show off some
nice.5 features
okay
so uh let's put some proper models in
here
i have already prepared here some data
models so i'm
not boring you with typing we're putting
them in so it's very really a simple
data model
some author that has a name and an id
and an also has some books
and a book has a author
and title and uh yeah an author id
so very simple model then we have some
uh
db context which at the moment screams
at me because i
didn't have any entity framework
reference here we will fix that in a bit
but it's basically a simple db context
we will be using sqlite here
and we call that demo um
and yeah it's a basic setup
so let's uh add some and i prepared
uh some commands so i also don't type
this is a new entity framework actually
what we are using here
uh entity framework five also preview
and uh let's add also some data
integration here
for hot chocolate that enables some uh
functionality i will walk you through as
we
upgrade the whole server okay so we
added some packages here
and in order to really run this thing we
need uh
to create a database and for this uh
there is some tooling
uh some local tools um for
entity framework i will install these
and then we basically run some like
create some migrations
and run them so we will end up with the
database
so it built the project now it should
yeah there's migrations coming here
and now we have a database
okay so let's build this server out
so in order to have to put entity
framework into our server
we first have to go get up here and add
entity framework
since graphql on queries executes in
parallel with multiple threads
it's actually not so good for entity
framework but
entity framework five allows to use
pooled db
contexts that we can rent and return
so each thread that then executes
something against an entity
context can have its own db context
without producing too much allocations
so this is now called add pooled db
context factory
and let me just grab
this guy here get rid of
this i just needed that for the um
for the database migration generation
and let's put that in here i'm not an
anti-framework guy actually so
i'm not
as let's reload that
wait a second add pulled
yes that actually should work
let's compile that
what what ah yes
i forgot to specify the db context that
we want to use so it's the books
the book books no book context
and then we say import stuff here
yes and now it will work
yeah import this and
now we are out of the woods that's uh as
far as i know about entity framework
and as far we need for the talk so
the next thing really with um a query
type
we can head back here let's get rid of
our simple resolver here
and put some proper database logic in
here
this could also be some other database
technology as i said
so in this instance we are using a
variable of
maybe book and we call this get books
and then we need some db context
so let's put the db context in here book
context
context and maybe just
return from the book context the books
and actually let's do that the same
thing for the authors
get author and
in this instance we are returning the
authors
so this is basically this is very simple
stuff
but i said graphql is executing in
parallel
so how do we inject this stuff
there is something called the middleware
in graphql it's a field middleware
and we can annotate field middlewares
onto our resolver methods
so we can say use db
context
import that this is one of the things
that i installed basically with the
packages that i installed for hot
chocolate
and now i can just define which book
context i want
and then i specify here that this is
actually a scoped a field scoped context
so it just lives for the execution
field scoped service sorry and it just
lives for the time of the execution of
this field
and the same let's do here
and also just steal this attribute put
it here
and let's rerun our server it should
already
work
okay let's rerun that
go back here re-fetch the schema
we get books and we can click on that
we can see that we not only have the top
level fields we can really
drill in we have the um the books
collection that we have here we can see
the author and we could drill in forever
so we didn't do a lot just two lines of
code actually
and this entity uh framework stuff and
we already have
um quite a populated schema we just can
query this stuff we already could
ask for some data let's let's just try
that
um books and maybe get the title
but there is no data in it right so we
are asking for
stuff that we didn't we don't we don't
have yet
so we don't get any data back
okay so in order to put some data in
here
we actually
we actually and and that's why i
actually got an arrow
just fix that
on that again still get the narrow
demo db demo db should work actually
let me do one more check
should it be get
now it should be it should work to be
working
so i have the book context here context
there
work everything so let's debug live
debugging
not here take
this instance
get the schema
type in our query and then we will get
the debug errors
because if you start the server actually
in debug it will tell you what
it what is happening so we get a 500 we
can look at the response
response and can see that it cannot
get the uh get the context actually
ah yes i know so it's telling us that
the
db context actually is missing uh the
correct constructor
it has um it has i would say the correct
constructor
it's not correct compiled
okay but i
have a fallback solution so let's just
wrap
for my working solution
as i said
which actually looks the same
okay on that again
and now it should work i would guess
it doesn't work
past books
so let's let me just grab my
um query over and then
let me see what is wrong
it's always when you practice it it
always works out but then the moment you
are
doing it live it's
crashing and burning
okay so let's switch over to my
other project which i have already
prepared and i walk you through it
project
okay
ah alright
project
like sorry for that
now it's building okay
this should not work
okay so it really is broken
and i don't know why
okay i'll walk you through through it a
bit and then we'll
uh see maybe we find the error that my
system
has it usually works but
maybe i'm too tired to see it okay
so basically what we did is we
built some queries out and here we see
the
more advanced version of the of the
query
uh it's enough actually to inject the db
context here and then return just some
data
and what we can actually do to improve
that
is actually put in some filtering so we
could just annotate
another middleware that basically is
built in in hot chocolate
and allows us to rewrite the
um draft code queries that coming into
native sql
via entity framework and also do some
sorting on top of it
if we look at our schema
which i hope we get
then we can see if we look at the books
resolver that we have some proper filter
logic here
like i could um see that my filter
allows for and or operations i can drill
into
the ids into the fields do nested
searches on that
so if i actually went here to my
books resolver now i could
join into the where
look for instance for books that are
written by a certain author
and the certain author should have a
name maybe
the name should contain
should contain maybe an m and then we
would
be able to actually fetch that
let me just try one more time i cannot
believe that this is broken
that makes me kind of sad such a cool
demo
yeah it's really broken entity framework
it is really a shame
does the bee have books it does
and you can see here that the good thing
is on my error here that you can see
that it really translated this query
into proper sql
so you can see um i asked for the
authors and stuff
and it transferred it really into
the name no such table books
do you know let's let's try that let's
get rid of the
table and just
just next time i'm using
so just i'm re-running the
the migration and actually
in order to rerun that properly
we need
to kind of change the db context
this guy here data data
demo copy
data books context
yeah i don't think we get that
so for the migrations i need to
construct
less
yeah this one
and then just protect it
okay this is now a last ditch effort to
get this
demo running
i also have a blog about this but
okay so we then we call it books
i'm so sorry for that
come on
yes that's okay now it's migrating
and we're getting a database finally
so now we need a constructor here this
guy has to go right
out because we are pooling this db
context
let's run
okay let's see
hey it works
okay sorry guys so now let's let's walk
the
walk you through again we have uh
15 more minutes left let's let's have a
look at how this actually
works um
okay we have no data in here so we could
we can query but we don't have data
so i already built some mutations let's
go to the mutation type here
mutation is like a query type a simple
class
that we just call mutation and the
mutation
also has resolvers and these mutation
resolvers
actually are executed serially because
they
perform side effects on your system
there's a very important aspect in
graphql only the top level fields of a
mutation
are considered mutations everything
beneath that
is already a query on your
of the on the changed state of the
server that is why
we get an input here which is called add
author
input which represents the raw data the
user provides
and we are mapping that onto
our author object then we're adding it
to the db context we are saving our
changes here
and then we are returning our author
payload with the
change state in this case the author
object
okay so let's try a mutation out
so in graphql mutation starts with the
keyboard mutation
and this part up here is called actually
an operation
so we can give it a name like add author
and then we call the mutation that we
want which is
called in this case at author
and then we pre provide the data which
in this case is
just the name let
let's add myself as an author i'm not a
book writer but
and then we can maybe reselect the
author and from the
author that we reselect we just want the
id let's do that
we write that in
to the piano
today is not my happy day
never had that
let's see if that
yeah it's it's really
not good today yeah it shouldn't be
actually uh there okay i know what it is
okay there is in in mac os if you push
option and space
it actually produces a symbol
that is not readable that is not
possible and messes up every json and
graphql you have okay i added the author
here
now let's add a book
so we get some data in there so we can
explore how that actually
works alone so
we're editing again some data here
through our input
something about graphql
and then we add the author id like one
and we reselect something from the book
like the
id again to check and update maybe our
client store we file that we get the
book id back
so now we have some data in here and now
we can use some
query for the data and i can already see
that there is something wrong here
so let's and just write new
and for instance we are asking like like
we did before for the books
we are querying here for the books that
are written by an author and the
author's name
should contain
that should contain maybe an m
just play it safe and then we want to
fetch
the book title and
the author's name
and then we already saw it's translating
that
to proper sql we get our data back
and it works so we can give our user
a lot of filtering capabilities here
and let you really bind
graphql to your entity framework
context or to your business logic
depends on
uh which way you're going
so this is basically the data
integration part
let's just have a look how that works
um what i annotated there these
attributes that you saw in the code let
me just go back
and have a look at that these queries
that let
that these attributes here like
filtering sorting use the b
context these are all middlewares and
these
middlewares allow me to alter the
execution
pipeline of a field and it basically
allows me
to in this case to alter the variable
and change it so that the that it
produces some other sql
than before like in this instance uh
paging middleware yields always to the
next one
until the end where the resolver
produces some data in this case the
variable
and then we return and apply sorting
filtering projections and
paging at the end the graphql survey
produces the result okay
we have nine minutes left so let's look
at subscriptions
uh with graphql and for the
subscriptions
we actually need to introduce a new type
and the type is called subscription
and in this case the subscription type
looks very simple
because i only have to um create a
resolver that
represents an event on my system and
in this in this case every time a book
is released or published i want to
raise an event and the event is just
waiting the
returning a book so every time a book is
released i get a real-time event
over this book and um
in order to the payload for my event
shall be the book itself in real
implementations it might be an int or
representing the book that we would load
with the data loader or stuff like that
but in this demo we just use a book so
we annotate this
argument actually with an event message
and then return the book
in order to tell the system that this is
a subscription we
basically say this is a subscribe
resolver
and the topic of this we subscribed
resolver shall be
this method name here
because we have a very static event in
this case
the next thing is we need something to
trigger this event
so we go back to our mutation and
basically
insert there the topic event sender
this is the abstraction of the hot
chocolate
event system the pub sub system that
sits beneath that
[Music]
okay and after we have
written everything to the database we
will send
to that pub sub system uh
the message and this is our topic as i
said we use a method name at the moment
topic and we just send in the book
and then basically the subscription is
triggered and if
somebody subscribed to that he or she
gets the data
in order to set this all up we have to
go to our startup cs
and then add in this case in memory
subscription
we also support redis
and also registers a subscription type
here
okay then let's go back here
so that means every time i actually
write a book at the book here
i will get
an event raised for this i need
two banana cake pops so i'll take this
one
let's refresh that
okay let's get the events
and now i can just say i want to subs i
want a subscription which start with
subscription
and then i subscribe to the event that
we just declared
and from the event every time a book is
released i want the title
and i also want the author and the
author's name
and then i can fire the subscription up
and what happens is actually nothing we
just get this
donut here going on and if we now
execute we can see the data is coming
in real time and we could change it
and then can see every time we do
something we get a new event
so this was graphql subscriptions uh
sorry guys that i messed this up so much
um usually it works uh out quite well
but this time it really crashed and
burned
as a conclusion is with graphql you can
iterate faster
and that means front end and backend can
do much more work because the backend
developers basically can create a schema
that represents the
domain model for your business case or
for your business
and the from the developer can just pick
and choose and fetch data
from that as they need that
it takes away the complexity from data
fetching
because the you just
describe those rest requests those
graphql requests and
send them to the backend over http
and you get just the data back in the
same structure that you requested
and that makes it super easy to consume
graphql
can recommend the book which is
production-ready graphite from
uh mark andre he's uh he works at github
and has a lot of experience about schema
design and if you start a bigger graphql
project
it's a good book to go to
and start learning about graphql
our project is open source you can head
over to
chilecream.com
or you can also go to github slash chili
cream that's actually our chocolate
to check out the latest uh version we
have a slack channel
um if you need help or want to get
started with this head over to our slack
channel and we get
uh you started with graphql
again sorry for the demo
and if you have questions
then please ask i saw again a message
here
let me read i missed it on the escrow
logs under the hood
the is the sql query doing a select scan
or as a
select star or just the fields you ask
for
it depends so in this example i didn't
use projections
but we also have a projections
middleware
actually uh the block i looked up from
myself
here is a block on devtio
and this uses projection in this case
and it would also just select what you
asked for
um let me see
it okay it's it's a bit longer but you
can see the selections attribute
and this will actually then cause the
uh requests to be exactly rewritten to
uh
sql requests you can read this
blog post but somewhere yeah there you
can see their square is where it really
writes
not a select star but actual fields that
you requested
but selections uh projections graphql
are actually
rarely do them because there are more
efficient ways to fetch data like
data loaders which actually batch than
the requests but would
fetch everything but in a graph it's
highly possible that you
select entities multiple times and with
batch data loaders you
with data loads you can reuse those
entities
if you have there's another questions
let me just okay so great talk things uh
how does banana cake pop compare with
other
tools like graphical so banana cake pop
is still in preview also coming out at
the end of october
it's much richer can fetch
much larger schemas
also we support things like the fur and
banana cake pop
supports things that like defer you
can save documents you cannot do that
with
a graphic url so you can save up your
documents
we will also when it's released allow
you to sync the documents
with github and other sources
so you can store them somewhere
then there is another question how does
hot chocolate compare with other.net
servers like roughgrad.net
it's very simple hot chocolate is the
fastest graphical server on the.net
platform
uses eight times less memory than
graphql.net for instance
and also supports more features
like uh i think they are not even
thinking about the for we are actually
the first
graphql server overall that released
defer
from the new draft spec of graphql so if
you want to have the latest graphql
features
and that is hot chocolate
and also uh yeah check out our product
project it has
so much more integrations into
background systems
uh if you if i have a data source that
aren't in a database can i tie them into
graphql by implementing an interface
if i have a data source
yes you can you can
so you can mix data together we also
hot chocolate also supports schema
stitching that means you can
rewrite data from everywhere so and that
is really
very simple like this is a local graphql
server now at the moment
but i could just go in here and say
add remotes at i don't have the
i don't have the uh stitching package
but as soon as you put the stitching
package in
you can just say add remote
schema and then you can fetch another
graphql schema from somewhere else
and merge it with your local graphql
schema you can do that also with odata
also only in the new version
is long polling when it executes the
subscription now it's not yet long
pulling banana cake pop uses web sockets
and the graph
subscription specification but
it is possible to do it also over signal
ah
there are other questions
how do you prevent a graft endpoint from
becoming monoliths
actually you want graphql to become a
monolith so
um oh actually do you want the
schema to become a monolith and
just as a comparison facebook has the
biggest
or largest draft prize out there with uh
with over 10 000 times types 300 000
fields and it's an absolute monolith but
with the graphql servers at the house
they are including
hot chocolate you can do things like
schema stitching
break your graphql server in various
domain services and then have a single
gateway
that automatically stitches them
together to one graphql endpoint
but this schema you want to have one
source of truth
but you can split it over many servers
services
so there are techniques schema stitching
it's uh
if you go to the chili cream
website you can check that out
ah there's schema stitching and there's
an introduction how you can merge
schemas together
you